okay larry kudlow is with uh
fox business he said we are fighting for
the souls of america for the soul of
america we are fighting for this very
soul of this great country and there's
no better way to
do it than to compare the ultra blue
state of california versus the ultra red
state of florida
california had some of the hardest
coveted lockdown measures while florida
was among one of the first
states to reopen way back in may of
2020.
california's economy has a 7.9
unemployment rate florida is below five
percent california has a 13.3 percent
top income tax rate florida does not
have an income tax california has
amongst
the biggest homeless population in the
country though it has only 12 percent of
america's population
california has one quarter of america's
homeless let me read that one more time
even though california only has 12
percent of america's population
california has a quarter 25 percent of
america's homeless
florida is america's free estate
according to cato institute survey
number one in fiscal freedom number one
in educational freedom
cato dubs california one of the least
free states
and flat out dubs it the most cro
croniest state in the union
new york post columnist kylie smith says
again
the most croniest state in the union
cronius means
people who are able to buy politicians
in that state to get any agenda they
want to get past it
adam your big larry kudlow guy what do
you think about what he has to say about
this yeah i actually
you know he's on fox business he was um
at one point
for a brief stint for like less than a
year trump's
economic advisor is on his council look
there you you talked about being a
wordsmith
earlier about the new york times uh
larry carlos did some wordsmithing here
especially
or wartsmith that's really can i
you call statswortsmithing can i say my
point
but but you called you smithing i'm
asking you a question
did i get can i stand my point you
usually ask me what's my point yeah i'm
about to get to my point i want i'm
sorry i'm talking about the stats
tell me tell me here's my note since
you're so rudely interrupted so tell us
i said he's right but it's over dramatic
as an example
here's my problem with him yeah the
ultra red state of florida are you
willing to say that florida is
ultra red but by the way today texas
isn't even ultra rare hear me out today
today many people would say florida's
more red than texas today
many people would say florida and texas
has have switched in the last 18 months
i don't agree with that however i don't
know he may have been
saying the government is ultra red but
let's hear your brilliant point
i think look as someone who has lived in
florida's whole life i think you would
be willing to say
desantis has done a good job here marco
rubio little marco rubio rick scott
these are both
senators republican senators i'm just
taking notes buddy
alabama west virginia mississippi states
that no one's
trying to live in by the way sure when
you move valuetainment you didn't think
well what's going on in west virginia
this month
that didn't happen i definitely didn't
think california new york either okay
yeah
exactly and the whole reason look
the numbers are true i'm not debating
that my whole thing was he's right but
it's dramatic
it's a dramatic effect this is
wordsmithing here yeah the ultra red
state of florida no this is as purple as
it gets
it's voted uh clinton it's voted obama
it's voted trump
it's voted by like it goes either way
however i think
larry kudlow has a major point here i'm
in florida i'm thankful for living in
florida it's the free estate in the
goddamn union
respect now let's talk to a socialist
over here from california yeah okay go
back to your point
yeah wort smithing stats i'm saying i
didn't
i didn't say anything about the stat
pack i agree with the stats
i said he's right and he's true he's
just over dramatic
okay what the overdramatic part is ultra
exactly that's my point but the stats
tell a very
and i agree with this i'm not i'm not
questioning this right the stats tell
you
exactly what's going on in florida and
not california yes let's talk to
accountability
do you know how many people i've brought
over here yeah and they've stayed here
for a week
let's just say okay i went to a
restaurant the other day
whatever it's called the blue moon
something something where it's right
across
for a lot it's actually a real nice
restaurant i don't know what it's called
a nice restaurant you go pay lunch is
like
you know uh he pays blue martini i don't
know what it's called nice restaurant on
the water
so i'm there i'm leaving uh uh and i'm
getting to valet this
65 year old ladies outside with a mask
on
and she says i cannot believe the level
of irresponsibility
of these people in florida how do you
guys dare walk around without a mask on
and dylan and tico and cena right next
to me right
and my dad next to me i'm like really i
said man i'm so sorry you feel that way
where are you from i'm from california
we are responsible there
really yeah what part of california what
do you know about california
i may know a little bit about where are
you from mission viejo do you know where
that's at yeah i lived in california 24
years in socal
okay i see you know what i've noticed
about californians she said what
i said i've noticed in californians
whether you're left or right you're
miserable today
why because the ones who are on the left
who believe everybody should wear a mask
they think everybody's an idiot who
doesn't wear a mask and they're so
bitter
and the ones on the right are so bitter
today because they don't want to be
forced to wear a mask
california has become bitter county and
there's a lot of people that are bitter
like yourself
and nobody can make anybody happy in
california that's why a lot of people
men from your state are coming to states
like texas and florida
whatever what are the odds that she ran
into you
in the valet line come on so anyways
what are your thoughts my thoughts are
hey you know i'm going to take the
positive spin here 12
of the population lives in california we
have 25 percent of the
homeless population we're over achievers
i mean we're amazing
you know here's the thing at what point
do people with common sense and
intelligence understand that um
it doesn't have to continue to be this
way there are alternatives
and it starts with government and and
you know what we have the big election
coming up here i don't know if we have a
shot or not but
it's easy to take shots at california
right now because we deserve it and you
don't see a lot of hope
um he's also very good at getting the
attention he he said that
he sees florida and south florida
replacing wall street i just don't see
that happening do you
i mean could you actually actually it
would take
this state state like not state as a
state of texas
it would take the state the current
state of economy in new york to stay
like this for a decade
if it does it can happen but if it
changes if california and new york
change within the next 18 months let's
just say larry elder announced yesterday
he's running for governor for california
i don't know if you heard that or not
last night larry you know larry elder
who helped flip i think uh
conservative yeah black conservative he
announced yesterday he's running for
governor of the state of california
david rubin david rubin david
and larry elder's got a big following in
the state of
california he's got a big following
period he's obviously loved and hated
because he's hated he's got a lot of
people that can't stand what he stands
for because he's a conservative in the
city of california
california is right now getting a lot of
people that are going to be running if
the politics in california and new york
changes there's no way that's going to
be happening to florida
but if california and new york stay like
this for another decade
he's absolutely right florida will be
the next wall street
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye